thank you ted it's open enrollment time
and here to help us navigate such an
important topic is patrick castle
with the multi-care group patrick thank
you so much for joining us now
open enrollment it usually runs until
the 15th
for january first effective date but
this year is a little different can you
tell us why
there's a covid we're going to we're
going to we're rolling into um
january 15th for a february first
effective date
so people may have some extra time than
it sounds like for open enrollment
well if you want a january 1st effective
date we need to enroll you by tomorrow
but you could go on for february if you
wanted to as well
i guess if there's a silver lining that
would be it now
if someone has a provider that they want
to stay with it's important
to let you know can you explain why that
is so important
because you know there's only so many
plans out there and there's only so many
providers that are taking those plans so
it's best that you let us know
where you're at and we'll be able to
help you find the best plan to fit your
budget
as well as most importantly have your
doctors you guys have a lot of good
information for people that are going
through this process right now how about
if you're seeking
a tax credit and you want to be on the
silver state exchange
what do you need to do in that case we
need to know their approximate income
for 2021
not what happened in 2020 so if they're
collecting unemployment going into next
year
they got a new job or they're getting
any kind of money for retirement we need
to know what kind of money they're
getting
now that yeah that's really going to
determine what happens what if
let's say god forbid they close the
strip and people are unemployed again
what can they do well
they're going to have several options
they may be able to stay on their
current plan maybe
the casinos will give an extension
number one number two if they're
terminated then they have it they can
look at cobra but this is where
if their income is going down they can
qualify for some great tax credits for
the silver state exchange
now if you could just tell us what's the
most popular question you get asked by
people that are going through this open
enrollment process something that you
think everyone needs to know the most
popular question is
can i use this plan outside the state of
nevada and the answer is no
unless it's an emergency the answer is
no you're stuck here in nevada to use
the doctors in the back of nevada
so it's very important and vital that
you tell me who your doctors are
so we can assign you the right plan you
really have
all the answers and the multi-care
groups clients they are provided
personalized services and are there to
maximize your benefits when you need
them
so make sure you give them a call
patrick can answer all of your questions
the number is 702-396-9449 or
just visit themulticaregroup.com